den Krieg verfolgen Sie rund um die Uhr
geschätzt 300.000 Menschen mit
palästinensischen Wurzeln leben in
Deutschland die meisten in Berlin sie
hoffen täglich auf Lebenszeichen von
Freunden und Familie in Gaza was mich am
meisten interessiert ob sie noch am
Leben sind dieses noch ist das halt was
mich seit 6 Wochen verfolgt diesen noch
am leben heute noch am Leben weil es
kann sich jeder Zeit ändern die sagen
das ist das schlimmste was sie bisher
erlebt haben auch ihre Familien sagen
schlimste was sie bisher erlebt haben
und sie haben mir mitgeteilt die haben
alles verloren wirklich alles falls Sie
das Überleben dann brauchen Sie unsere
Hilfe das ist die Nachbarschaft wo ich
geboren und aufgewachsen bin dort wurde
das Haus bombardiert die Familie meine
Schwester haben es überlebt und die sind
jetzt anderem Ort geflüchtet aber ob das
sicher ist da ist kein sicher Ort Nidal
bulbul ist Kulturschaffender lebt in
Berlin das ist seine Familie in
Ende September war er noch bei ihnen zu
Besuch jetzt hat er Angst sie nie
wiederzusehen und fordert eine
Waffenruhe sofort gezielter Gewalt von
beider Seiten muss verurteilt werden das
ist da werden wir nicht darüber
diskutieren aber das gibt Israel kein
Recht so ein massiver brutaler Angriff
an Gaza auszuüben und so viele Menschen
umzubringen ist IT Manager in Berlin
auch seine Geschwister samt Familien
sind die einen suchen im zeltlagerschutz
andere in einem angemieteten Keller
natürlich ist das was am 7 Oktober
passiert ist dieser dieser Angriff gegen
Zivilisten die unschuldig sind ist ist
ein terroristischer Akt natürlich
natürlich aber das rechtfertigt nicht
die Antwort wo auch Zivilisten in diesem
Ausmaß dann sterben das kann das kann es
nicht rechtfertigen es ist nicht der
erste Krieg in Nahost den er von
Deutschland aus mitterlebt der Konflikt
begleitet sein Leben doch diesmal ist es
anders er findet es fehlt an Empathie
für ihn ein Bruch Leute die mich kennen
die wissen dass ich dass ich Familie
inasa habe die wissen aber auch meine
Position zu religiösen fanatischen
Organisationen etc
etc und da erwarte ich schon dass sie
das das Mitleid und Empathie zeigen in
so einer Situation ja wie wir sehen den
Schmerz wie sehen das Leid unabhängig
davon ob wir jetzt das dies Thema
politisch so oder so einschätzen ja und
das habe ich immer wenig also es habe
ich extrem wenig erlebt dieses Mal
Dialog ist möglich Empathie für beide
Seiten das wollen sie zeigen seit dem 7
Oktober sprechen Joan hassun
deutschpalästinenserin und Schai
Hoffmann deutscher Jude mit israelischen
Wurzeln in Schulen über den
Nahostkonflikt mit dem Ziel dass wir
irgendwann mal eine Einigung haben bzw
dass wir uns auf Menschlichkeit besinnen
und es nicht darum geht auf eine Seite
zu stehen oder zu relativieren alles
andere also Hass und Hetze wird uns hier
in Deutschland in unserer Gesellschaft
nicht weiterbringen und die hat auch
leider den Israelis und Palästinensern
nichts gebracht seit Jahrzehnten die
Nachfrage ist riesig mehrfach die Woche
sind sie in Schulen es geht auch darum
Gefühlen Raum zu geben den Schmerz der
anderen zuzulassen und
anzuerkennen auch wenn ich das Leid
meiner Familien Israel sehe sehe ich
auch gleichzeitig das Leid der
Palästinenser und PalästinenserInnen im
Gaza bzw auch die Kämpfe die
Palästinenser innen hier in Deutschland
führen müssen diese ganze Palästina
Israel Frage wird meistens auch leider
dafür benutzt von Hetzern und auch
gekarpert von Hetzern um Stimmung zu
machen und wo wenig Platz dann noch für
uns palästinensischen Menschen ist und
dann kommt noch die Frage mit dem dieses
distanzieren sich von der Hamas zu
distanzieren oder sich von Terror zu
distanzieren was habe ich persön
Palästinenserin oder als Mensch der hier
aufgewachsen ist was habe ich mit der
Hamas zu tun am 8 November waren Joan
hassun und Schai Hoffmann zu einem
runden Tisch ins Schloss belvü geladen
ein Treffen für ein friedliches
Miteinander in Zeiten des Krieges
Bundespräsident frankwalter Steinmeier
wendet sich in seiner Ansprache direkt
an Menschen mit arabischen und
palästinensischen
Wurzeln lassen Sie sich von den
helferselfern der Hamas nichtum
entalisieren sprechen Sie für sich
selbst der teilen Sie dem Terror eine
klare Absage deutschpalästinenser Raid
Naim hat sich die Rede mehrfach angehört
findet viele Teile sehr gut aber dass er
sich distanzieren soll nimmt er
persönlich ich war jahrelang in der
Friedensbewegung hab mit jüdischen und
israelischen Gruppen zusammengearbeitet
etc etc und wenn man das weiß würde man
nie auf die Idee kommen mich dazu
aufzurufen von der Hamas mich von der
Hamas zu distanzieren aber ich bin
aufgerufen worden weil man das so
pauschal gemacht
ja und das das ist gefährlich weil es
gibt das gibt den Leuten das Gefühl egal
was ihr persönlich individuell macht ja
ich sehe euch als Gruppe und die Gruppe
ist für mich kategorisiert in XY Z auch
Nidal bulbul ist deutscher Staatsbürger
er ist in Gaza geboren und aufgewachsen
hat dort für eine internationale
Nachrichtenagentur gearbeitet Krieg
dokumentiert und was es heißt im
Gazastreifen zu leben bei einem Angriff
der israelischen Armee 2007 verlor er
sein rechtes Bein in Berlin hat er sich
ein neues ein sicheres Leben aufgebaut
doch seit Ausbruch des Krieges sind
seine Gedanken nur noch in
Gaza unser Nachbarn aber auch Freunde
und enge Freunde von uns Arbeitskollegen
von Journalisten die noch da sind die
weiß ich selber nicht als jemand der
dort geboren und aufgewachsen wie das
aushalten
können ich frage mich jeden Tag wie wie
ein normaler Mensch mit ganz wenig sage
ich mal so versorgens für das Leben und
der Horror der jeden Nacht jeden jeden
Tag
hab sein Kopf dass der nächste Moment
nächste Rakete bist du
dran er sieht die Bilder von tausenden
Toten und fürchtet dass das nur der
Nährboden für noch mehr Hass sein
wird Menschen die komplett komplette
Familen 17 18 20 Mitglieder der Familie
ist komplett gestorben der ist einzilles
Ken geblieben was erwartest du als
internationaler Welt von diesem kennt er
wird aufwachsen und werdest du ihm
Fragen gon dem Hamas würdest du ihm
Fragen Frieden mit Israel weiß ich nicht
unschuldige Zivilisten leiden
unschuldige Zivilisten sterben und das
kann doch nicht die Lösung sein und
selbst wenn Hamas jetzt wieder die
Raketen
abwirft das ist schon schlimm aber
gucken Sie sich mal das an was da
eigentlich passiert was im Gasa
passiert man muss doch eine andere
Lösung
finden sie ist enttäuscht von der
internationalen Gemeinschaft FHT die
Welt an hinzuschauen Verzweiflung bei
all unseren Gesprächspartnern sie
fordern der Krieg muss
enden